byrne mes chers collègues il y a dix
huit jours la france était en état de
choc à la suite de la tuerie des quatre
membres de la préfecture de police de
paris par un fonctionnaire radicaliser
il a fallu plusieurs jours
non sans cafouillages et avec des pudeur
sémantique plusieurs jours de
balbutiement politique malgré la
réactivité des enquêteurs pour admettre
que l'assassinât reposait sur des motifs
religieux
certes deux missions ont été annoncés à
juste titre dans le premier ministre
pour détecter les agents a légalisé dans
les services antiterroristes l'une de
ses missions est relative à la fameuse
direction du renseignement de la
préfecture de police de paris qui dès
2015 aurait dû s'apercevoir du
changement d'apparence et de
comportement de ce fonctionnaire la
réorganisation ou le rattachement de la
drpp s'impose
près de trois semaines après cette
tuerie rien n'a été fait les français
demandent des décisions immédiates au
moment où le gouvernement a reconnu
cette sécession insidieuse qui menace la
société les dérives communautaires de
certains employés de service public
exposées sont alarmantes parle a bien
conscience des élites des signes
évidents de radicalisation dans ces
services sont tus c'est même le mot
radicalisation qui fait peur on n'ose
pas désigner l'ennemi alors que nous
sommes en lutte contre l'islamisme
politique comme l'a dit bruno retailleau
le communautarisme prépare le terreau
des vocations jihadistes de demain à
chaque problème
l'exécutif tempête nous sommes devenus
coutumiers de ces indécisions permanente
là comme dans bien des domaines
monsieur le ministre castaner à la suite
de la tuerie commise au coeur de
l'institution policière
je n'ose plus vous demander ce que vous
comptez faire pour que le drame de la
préfecture de police ne se renouvelle
pas puisque hélas nous ne vous croyons
plus